this next comment hasn't even performed
but i'm already laughing
please give a warm welcome this is a
true legend
to the goal hey everyone it's me judy
gold back at banana moore's comedy club
my favorite club in the entire world
uh so i have a birthday coming up which
is uh
you know i'm happy i'm happy that i'm
having a birthday but i feel a lot of
stress because now
i don't know who started this but
whenever you go on social media you go
on facebook
every time it's someone's birthday they
have a birthday fundraiser
where they raise money for charity who
thought of this i just want attention
i want a cake i want people to call me i
want to get wasted
that's what i want for my birthday i
don't need to worry about raising money
for someone less fortunate than me i do
that every other day of the year
but you know some of these charities are
i mean they're ridiculous
i recently read one on facebook hi my
birthday is next week and i'm raising
money this year
for my favorite charity cww cats without
whiskers
many felines are born without whiskers
and i have no peripheral vision
and i'm bumping into things and getting
run over by bicycles
people lawnmowers cww
provides prosthetic whiskers for those
kittens
who are born without them so that they
can live a happy
and perfect life okay you know what i
already picked up my charity
so i want you to check it out this year
on my birthday
i am raising money for my favorite
charity
chase checking account number one two
four six
seven eight nine three eight five that's
one two four
six seven eight nine three eight five
this is why i can't stand facebook i
really can't you know
the social media thing it's so crazy
because you can
never live up to the life that you
present
you know what i mean i have so many
friends they are in the most miserable
horrible relationships and then you know
i i get calls from them all the time you
know what i can't take it anymore i feel
like i'm in jail
i have to get out of this relationship
the minute i have enough money i am
moving out
i can't take it i don't know what oh my
god here she comes i gotta go bye
and then ten minutes later i'll look on
facebook happy anniversary to the love
of my life
here's to 25 more blissful
years together give me a break
that's it for me folks this has been an
amazing
amazing night here or day here at
bananamores
can't wait to come back and uh tip your
weight staff
try the veal if you're vegan try the
vegan veal and uh goodnight everybody
laugh at your screen
thanks for coming to bananamores